-Welcome back!
-Hello!
-I always -- I want to start by
saying thank you, of course,
because, of course, you have
a show tonight.
You're making time for us.
I really appreciate that.
-It's all right.
Ten news stories will break
between this moment.
-So in a way,
I'm doing you a favor
because if you were at work
right now,
you would be writing something
that would already be old
by the time you're on at 9:00.
-Yes.
-So I'm just giving you
an hour off.
-You know there --
I'm a disorganized person.
And I have bad time management.
And so I've always
had this problem
ever since I started doing work
like this,
where I produce stuff that
doesn't make it on to the show
for whatever reason --
other stuff goes long
or I can't end an interview on
time -- I have no discipline.
So there's always been some
stuff I have to kick out.
But now every single day,
the entire show I throw away
two hours before air time and
have to invent a whole new one.
I feel like I should just
come in at 8:00
before the 9:00 show
and be like, "Hit me now!
Hit me now! I'm just going to
ad-lib the whole thing."
I threw away a whole show
every day.
-It is nuts.
This is an unprecedented time.
And it has affected not only
our show, not only your show,
but it actually affected
your signoff the other night.
-Oh, God.
Yeah, you know, there are --
Like, throughout the history of
people doing news on television,
there has been all these,
like, really noble signoffs --
"courage," you know,
"good night and good luck."
-Yes.
-People do, like, you know?
It's been all these
very serious ones.
And people don't necessarily
try them anymore.
I have inadvertently
developed one
that I started doing
without trying to.
-It started when I was talking
about Steve Bannon,
the White House strategist guy.
You know, the grim reaper guy?
-It already feels like
a million years ago, yeah.
-I know.
He was in Congress.
And he wasn't answering
their questions
because his lawyer
was advising him not to.
And his lawyer
was advising him not to
because he was on the phone
with the White House.
And the White House was saying,
"We don't want Steve
answering those questions."
Turns out Steve Bannon's lawyer
is also the lawyer
for the guy at the White House
he was talking to.
-So, here's your new signoff,
which I think -- I don't know.
I think it's as good as
all of them.
-Okay.
-Let's take a look.
-Having somebody on those two
different sides of the story
both represented
by the same attorney?
That's weird.
That does it for us tonight.
[ Laughter ]
-"That's weird. Good night."
-"That's weird. Good night!"
Yeah. Sleep well.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I'm sure you'll talk about
this, this evening.
The memo.
We talked a little bit
about the memo.
Do you think the release of
this memo,
which seems inevitable
at this point,
do you think it will escalate
the investigation
into Trump and Russia ties,
if that's even possible?
Or do you think the takeaway,
when we look back on this memo,
will be this was a degrading of
our institutions
that someone in Congress
would basically
go after the Justice Department
and the FBI like this?
-Well, the memo isn't part of --
It isn't like something
that's been revealed
from the investigation.
The memo is part of
the Trump White House
and the Trump supporters
in Congress
trying to make the investigation
go away.
So this is part of their defense
against the investigation.
And there was a guy who was
a part of the Trump campaign,
he was a foreign adviser --
foreign policy adviser
to the campaign.
And he had been caught up
in a Russian spy ring
in New York City in 2013.
And, like, FBI
counterintelligence
had been involved in, like,
breaking up the spy ring.
And people went to prison.
And it was for real.
Then he turns up
on the Trump campaign,
and in the middle of
the Trump campaign,
he goes to Russia and gives
an anti-U.S./pro-Putin speech.
So, like, the
counterintelligence folks
are interested in this guy
because they're supposed to
monitor people
who might be foreign agents
in the United States.
And they got warrants
to surveil him
starting during the campaign.
And it got renewed
a bunch of times,
including into
the Trump campaign.
This whole memo thing is about
trying to make it a scandal
that it was renewed the most
recent time it was renewed.
-Yeah.
-"And that means there should be
no investigation."
It's like, "No, dude."
You had the guy with the Russian
spies working on --
and then going to Moscow
and being like,
"I love Putin.
I hate America."
Like, of course, the FBI is
gonna look into him.
So they're gonna try to say
that means there shouldn't be
a Russia investigation.
And it's been
a very big distraction,
which I think is effective.
But I don't think it will --
I don't think it will change
anything on Robert Mueller's
to-do list.